[Music]
so I'm just sitting down to watch Andor
this series I'm actually really looking
forward to and in a minute I'm going to
tell you exactly what I think of the
first few episodes so welcome to
Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV the movie
channel
[Music]
so first of all a little bit of a
spoiler warning there will be little
bits I mentioned in the video that if
you haven't seen the three episodes
might ruin it a little bit but I'm not
going to tell you that whole story
what's the point you can watch it
yourself I'll just raise a few points
that I thought was interesting when I
watched it and then I really want to
start the debate in the comments where
you just get in there and tell everyone
else what you've thought and you know
have that discussion so without further
Ado let's crack on with it first
instinct is android looks like Wally
it's not set up Tatooine which is good
and it is dark and gritty like we were
promised
so they dropped three episodes today
first one I'm gonna say I'll tell you in
a bit there was a very clear reason why
they dropped three episodes
um it's one of the reasons I actually
quite like stream and services to be
honest because they can do things like
this when it makes sense to the story
they don't have to just do an episode a
week they can drop three episodes or two
episodes or one episode every day and
then they can they can mix it up but
when it makes sense to store and it most
100 did in this case but the First
episodes well it started with a murder
um if you're not British and you never
watch tag it you will have no clue why I
said it like that but if you are British
and you watch tag it you'll be laughing
your Johnny socks off right now this guy
Andor he's looking for a sister spoiler
and two guys from the local protectorate
uh you know giving a bit of crap and try
to mug him Zoe
um and and then the next three episodes
really about him trying to leg a cause
he knows he's done a bad thing
a copper that's looking for the hero of
the story that's trying to solve the
murder he's an unlikable little twerp
isn't it
we get to know Cassian Andor a little
bit more in this movie obviously we've
got to know him in um Rogue one but in
this series we're really going to
understand why he'd get into the
position he did at the start of Rogue
one what made him so willing and so
angry against the empire and so willing
to fight against him the way he did I'm
going to tell you a bit about the style
of the series form
so that Disney for me haven't done the
best job with the movie so far except
maybe for rogue one I love Rogue one
um it was maybe a little bit longer than
it needed to be I thought it could have
been a little bit edited down a little
bit but let's be honest Star Wars has a
rhythm to it and has quite a steady Pace
to it and they continue this to be
honest
this is even more steady than normal
um like I say there is a steady Pace
things happen in a certain speed in Star
Wars
um the first two episodes in particular
of Andor are quite slow there's lots of
flashbacks
to Cassini and his Youth and why he's
where he is and why he's looking for
this is why he got separated from his
sister the planet that he grew up in is
actually quite interested in this Canary
so
um it just found out that there was an
Empire City
um it does seem to be a bit of a Lord of
the Flies thing going on here where
there's only kids been left behind
um there was some sort of accident toxic
thing spoiler
um but the shot in the second episode
when he comes out of the tree line and
he sees the mine where there was this
Dreadful accent this Imperial mine it's
actually quite a beautiful shot it's
really dramatic you um see the forest
that they live in and they all have blow
darts they have very little technology
um but you see bits of technology in the
background rusting away so for some
reason I say the young people were the
ones that were left behind the adults
all died and
um this is what happens when we leave
kids on their own but they built a
lovely little Community but they didn't
have really any technology but they
still survived you know if it wasn't for
actually all the aliens and the Sci-Fi
stuff you know like the flying
motorbikes and things this would be like
one of those Scandinavian murder mystery
type shows you know those dramas
that um are always really good if you
can be bothered to read the
um writing along the bottom and then the
BBC or somebody else makes uh not quite
a good version of a couple years later
it's pretty good drama
one thing I will say about all of these
Star Wars projects is obviously they're
all filmed in the United Kingdom and
there is a brilliant array of British
talent in this series again it's actors
that I know from other things growing up
you know like BBC dramas and stuff like
this over the years so I know them from
lots of different things that anybody
anywhere in this world wrong to have
seen them but I know these guys are
phenomenal actors and I don't know
there's something about a British actor
in particular when they're playing a
villain
um there's the Scottish actor in this
that is played a very aggressive he's
one of like the the police constabulary
jobs and he's a very aggressive Scottish
guy and I've seen him in lots of things
he always plays a complete Thug
um but it's something about the accent
that just sells it there's something
about a British accent that does a great
villain and um yeah they they really use
that in this series and along mate
continue because it's absolutely
phenomenal we get to see a little bit
about how The Empire Works in this
series as well so you've got this uh
what's it called corporate tactical
defense and they're basically a private
security firm and these are the guys
that are the main protagonist in the
series at the moment it was some of
their people who got murdered at the
start and that's how the third episode
sort of ends with them trying to get
cassia
so
in terms of how how the empire
particularly in early stages was set up
in another thing I really like about
this is the the technology that you see
in the spaceship designs it's something
that Star Wars in this TV series in
particular have done really really well
going from the Clone War designs and the
look of the spaceships into a New Hope
and just getting that blend between the
two
um the corporate Defense Force tactical
defense whatever you want to call them
they're police [ __ ] they come in in the
same season and they start the third
episode sorry and they land this
the design is actually if you look at it
really nicely sits between the two
it's something they obviously put a lot
of effort into and a lot of work into
and it really sells the show
well
end of episode two a couple more
characters have been introduced and
Andor is running
seriously
starting to build a bit of pace but I
gotta admit it's not been a great deal
of action just yet
it still feels like Star Wars don't get
me wrong but it is a little bit
different for the Star Wars genre but it
does fit in with the style of Rogue one
and how Rogue one fits in the greater
Star Wars Universe it's true by the end
of the second episode not there wasn't a
lot of action not a lot had happened
but by the end of the third episode or
there had been so by the end of the
third episode [ __ ] kicks off it just
does
um
there's some there's a great scene in
the warehouse there's some really good
shooting there's some great speeds to
scenes and everything there's a very
clever I quite liked how they use sort
of like gorilla tactics to escape
because I felt that sort of mirrored how
the Rebellion has to fight against the
empire that obviously the Empire has all
the resources in the universe and the
Rebellion has next to nothing a ragtag
you know crew Motley Crew sort of thing
so it's sort of it sort of mirrored that
in the way that they escaped and again
try not to spoil it too much for you
but 100 by the end of the third episode
it's sort of rounded off
it's it's sort of like the end of the
beginning here so
the first three episodes really are a
chapter of this story and I think that
it tells us that bit of the story it's
you know it's the end of the beginning
so everything is sort of set up we know
now how and or ends up moving in through
towards the rebellion and why
um so I thought that was really
interesting the way they did that and as
I said at the start of the video that's
why they dropped these three videos in
one week so that we got that
chapter of the story out of the way
straight away I also quite like these
are only like 30 35 minutes long but
Disney Plus
you think a show is 45 minutes long so
you sit there thinking I'm going to
watch this for 45 minutes without
realizing at the end of every episode
particularly in the Marvel and and Star
Wars ones it's like 20 minutes of credit
to the end it does might not but anyway
now I'm not a Star Wars fanatic like
some of you I had I would have missed
loads of the Easter eggs from this
episodes and um you know I really guys
want you to get into the comments now
and tell us exactly what you think what
did you see what are the Easter eggs did
you cancer that I missed what did you
think about the general feel because I
mean some of the initial critical
responses have been a bit Hit or Miss
they've said that this show is maybe
um it comes and goes it has Ebbs and
flows to it and it's maybe not a great
start to the series I actually disagree
I thought it was a brilliant start to
the series but it is very much in the
style of the series and style of the
film
but guys
for the more obsessive ones out there
what did you think and what do you hope
and see in the rest of the series
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification really helps us out and if
you enjoy the content make sure you hit
that join button because that really
supports the channel as always please
stay safe and I'll see you next time
[Music]